[S01] 你有没有想过一个呃极其日常的瞬间
[S01] 就是你在手机上刚修改了日历里的一个会议时间
[S01] 转过头在电脑上打开网页
[S01] 瞬间就能看到最新的安排
[S02] 嗯，一切都显得那么理所当然，对吧？
[S01] 没错，非常顺滑。但是你有没有想过，如果就在你修改完的那一秒，手机突然断网了，会发生什么？
[S02] 或者是地球另一端的同事啊，刚好也在修改同一个会议的时间。
[S01] 对，那后台绝对乱套了。所以，欢迎你加入我们今天的深度探索。在这里，我们要揭开那些日常科技背后隐秘的运作法则。
[S02] 是一次非常烧脑的旅程。
[S01] 绝对的。今天为了弄清楚这一切，
[S01] 我们将深入挖掘软件工程领域的一本圣经，也就是大名鼎鼎的《设计数据密集型应用》，很多人管它叫 DDIA。
[S02] 这本书那个确实把数据系统的底裤都给扒光了。
[S01] 哈哈，对，我们今天的使命很简单，就是要向你揭秘。当系统需要把你发的一条社交动态或者一个文档的修改，完美地保存在全球各地的几十台机器上时，工程师们究竟面临着怎样疯狂的挑战？
[S02] 还有他们是如何就是如何防止你的数据撕裂时空的？这确实是一个让人着迷的领域。
[S01] 是啊。
[S02] 因为我们平时总有一种错觉，觉得数据嘛就像放在抽屉里的文件，放进去它就安安静静地待在那儿了。
[S01] 锁上抽屉就万事大吉了。
[S02] 呃，其实在真实的分布式系统世界里，完全不是这样。为了保证速度，也为了防止某台机器突然坏掉，导致数据彻底丢失。同一份数据必须在世界各地的服务器上拥有很多个分身。
[S01] 狡兔三窟嘛。
[S02] 对，而一旦有了分身，真正的噩梦就开始了。你如何让所有的分身在任何时刻都保持绝对的步调一致？
[S01] 这就好比你给几百个朋友发同一条消息，怎么保证所有人看到的版本都是一模一样的？
[S02] 没错，太难了。
[S01] 所以为了解决这个同步的问题，如果我们顺着人的直觉来想，最简单的方案就是找一个老大来拍板。
[S02] 嗯，也是最传统的做法。
[S01] 这就引出了我们要探讨的第一种架构设计，叫做单主复制。也就是所有的写入操作，不管你是在纽约还是在北京，都必须经过这个唯一的领导者，然后由他把变更的指令下发给底下的追随者。
[S02] 为了让大家更直观的感受，那个我们可以把它想象成一个厨房，主厨就是那个领导者，底下的帮厨就是追随者。
[S01] 这个厨房的类比非常贴切，有主厨和帮厨，那就立刻引出了一个系统里最经典的困境，同步还是异步？
[S02] 对，这就非常关键了。
[S01] 如果主厨每切一刀都要死死盯着所有的帮厨，确认大家都切完同样的一刀了，他才敢去切下一刀，这就叫同步复制。
[S02] 它的好处是绝对安全。万一主厨突然晕倒了，任何一个帮厨都能立刻顶上，因为大家手里的进度呃是一模一样的。
[S01] 但代价就是极其低效。只要有一个帮厨去上了个洗手间，或者手脚慢了一点，
[S02] 整个厨房的运作就得完全停摆，所有人都在等他。
[S01] 对啊，所以现实中如果是那种每秒要处理千万次请求的大型网站，绝对不可能等所有帮厨确认，对吧？
[S02] 绝对不可能。所以现实中的数据库通常会妥协，选择异步复制，也就是主厨只管自己疯狂的切菜，切完就把菜谱往后一扔。
[S01] 让帮厨自己去捡。
[S02] 对，帮厨们在后面尽力跟上，主厨根本不在乎帮厨现在切到哪一步了。
[S01] 但这就引出了一个大问题，如果帮厨跟不上进度呢？其实这就是你我每一个普通人在上网时都可能遇到过的灵异事件。
[S02] 灵异事件这个词很准。
[S01] 比如你肯定经历过这种事，你在社交媒体上刚发完一条长篇大论，满心欢喜地刷新页面，结果发现帖子不见了。
[S02] 哈哈，然后吓出一身冷汗。
[S01] 对，以为自己被系统封号了，或者触发了什么违禁词，结果过了几秒钟，你再刷新一次，它又神秘地出现了。
[S02] 这就是异步复制带来的第一种典型异常，专业术语叫读己之写异常。
[S01] 读己之写，也就是读到自己写的东西。
[S02] 没错，当你点击发送的那一刻，你的帖子被写入了主厨节点。但是当你紧接着刷新页面去读取时，
[S02] 系统的负载均衡器很不巧的把你分配到了一个帮厨节点上。
[S01] 而那个帮厨还没抄完笔记？
[S02] 对，还没抄完主厨最新菜谱。所以在他的世界里，你的帖子压根儿不存在。
[S01] 难怪，那系统怎么解决这个问题？总不能弹窗告诉用户，请你耐心等帮厨抄完吧。
[S02] 肯定不行，
[S02] 系统必须在架构上打补丁。比如设定一个硬性规则，如果你查看的是你自己的个人主页，
[S02] 系统就强制让你直接去问主厨。如果是看别人的主页，那再去问帮厨。
[S01] 哇，这招很聪明，巧妙地用规则掩盖了物理时间差。
[S02] 算是障眼法吧，但这只是最基础的异常。还有一种更让人抓狂的叫做单调读异常。在这个异常里，你会亲眼目睹时间倒流。
[S01] 等等，时间倒流，这听起来就像科幻小说了。
[S02] 其实不罕见。你可以想象这样一个场景，你正在关注一场非常激烈的世界杯决赛比分。你第一次刷新页面，请求落到了一个跟得比较快的帮厨节点上。
[S01] 嗯，这时候比分是多少？
[S02] 你看到比分变成了一点零，主队进球了，你非常激动，过了两秒，你又刷新了一次，
[S02] 这次请求不巧落到了一个有严重网络延迟的帮厨节点上。
[S01] 完了，他的进度是落后的。
[S02] 对，在他的世界线里，进球这个事还没发生，于是你眼睁睁看到比分变回了零点零。
[S01] 哇，如果我是赌球的，我绝对会把手机砸了。
[S02] 呵呵，对你来说，你就是先看到了未来，然后又瞬间回到了过去。
[S01] 这还没完。如果说时间倒流让人抓狂，那接下来的第三种异常就直接摧毁因果律了，这就是一致前缀读异常。
[S02] 呃，这个确实最头疼。
[S01] 这里我必须提一下资料里那个极其经典的例子。想象一段对话，
[S01] 观察者先听到了K夫人的回答，通常大约十秒钟，然后才听到PONZ先生提出的问题，你能看到多远的未来？
[S02] 哈哈，这在分布式系统里是极其典型的因果关系错乱。
[S01] 如果把这个场景带入到大家常用的微信或者群聊里，就更好理解了。一个人问，你要嫁给我吗？另一个人回答，我愿意。
[S02] 但由于整个系统非常庞大，数据被分散存在不同的机器上，PONZ先生发出的问题被存入了一个网络极其拥堵的server分区。
[S01] 而K夫人的回答，走了一条畅通无阻的快车道。
[S02] 没错，
[S02] 作为旁观者的你，同时从这两个分区拉取聊天日志，结果就是你先看到了答案，后看到了问题。
[S01] 所以啊，
[S01] 单主厨这个主厨真的是太难当了，它不仅是个单点瓶颈，一旦它出了意外，整个厨房得乱作一团，而且还要忍受帮厨们因为动作慢导致的各种时空错乱。
[S02] 是的，维护秩序的成本太高了。
[S01] 既然找一个老大有这么多麻烦，那最顺理成章的下一步就是为什么我们不顾两个老大呢？
[S02] 多找几个主厨。
[S01] 对啊，如果北京的厨房太远，我们就在纽约再建一个厨房，各自配一个主厨。
[S02] 非常符合逻辑的推演。这就进入了第二种主流架构，也就是多主复制。顾名思义就是有多个节点都可以直接接受用户的写入请求。
[S01] 这种在跨国公司里应该很常见吧。
[S02] 非常常见，特别是跨地域运行的全球化应用。如果你在纽约，你每次修稿数据都要等北京的服务器确认，那个物理距离带来的延迟，现代互联网用户是绝对无法忍受的。
[S01] 会卡到让人怀疑人生。
[S02] 所以纽约有一个领导者，
[S02] 北京也有一个领导者，他们各自先快速处理本地的请求，然后在后台伊布里交换彼此的笔记。
[S01] 懂了，其实这也不仅仅是大公司的专利，
[S01] 我们每天都在不知不觉地使用多主架构。
[S02] 比如呢？
[S01] 比如那些主打离线优先的应用啊，像你在高铁上没有信号的时候，用文档软件打字，或者在手机日历上添加日程。在那个断网的瞬间，你的手机本身就变成了一个临时的主厨。
[S02] 对，本地节点当家做主。
[S01] 你在本地尽情修改，等有了网络，他再去跟云端的主厨交换数据。
[S02] 但这听起来像是一个完美的乌托邦，直到我们遇到了那个最可怕的噩梦。
[S01] 也就是写入冲突。
[S02] 写入冲突，这是多主架构的阿克利罗斯之种。假设你和你的同事正在协作编辑同一个文档，你在纽约的主厨那里把标题改成了A,他在北京的主厨那里把标题改成了B.两个主厨在后台一交换笔记傻眼了，到底听谁的？
[S01] 是啊，这怎么判定？解决冲突最简单的策略是什么？
[S02] 最简单粗暴的策略叫做LWW,也就是最后写入胜利。
[S01] 最后写入胜利。
[S02] 对，
[S02] 系统会给每一次写入操作都打上一个精确到毫秒的时间戳。当冲突发生时，数据库就背比时间戳，谁的时间更靠后，谁就赢。
[S01] 那另一个人修改的呢？
[S02] 直接悄无声息地丢弃掉。
[S01] 哼，等等，稍等一下，这听起来极度不靠谱啊。意思是数据库为了保持它内部所谓的绝对一致，会偷偷摸摸地删掉其中一个用户的成功操作，这难道不会造成巨大的灾难吗？
[S02] 确实会。
[S01] 这就好比我们俩同时向同一个联名账户里存钱，
[S01] 系统为了避免冲突，
[S01] 直接把我的钱抹零了。
[S02] 你的敏锐度非常高，这确实是分布式系统中的一个呃极其残酷的取舍。在很多场景下，LWW确实会导致严重的数据丢失。
[S01] 那为什么还要用它？
[S02] 因为它极其简单，而且能绝对保证所有副本最终一定能达成一致。如果你的应用场景只是更新用户的最后一次登录时间，那丢弃几毫秒前的记录完全无伤大雅。
[S01] 但如果是购物车或者协作文档，LWW就是一场彻底的灾难了。
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 说到购物车，
[S01] 资料里那个经典的Amazon购物车异常，简直让人哭笑不得。当你的手机和电脑上的购物车发生冲突时，如果系统的合并策略稍微偷点懒，比如只是简单的取个并集，你知道会发生什么吗？
[S02] 很多听众可能都遇到过类似的灵异事件。
[S01] 假设你在手机上把一本你不想要的书移出了购物车，但同时你的电脑在后台做了一次自动的并发同步，
[S01] 系统一对比，
[S01] 发现电脑的购物车里有这本书，手机的没有取并集一合并，好家伙。
[S02] 书又回来了。
[S01] 对，这本被你删掉的书又像僵尸一样死而复生了，硬生生逼着你买单。
[S02] 这个例子完美展示了要想在多主架构下自动解决冲突，需要极其高超的智慧，特别是像文本编辑这种需要精确到字符层面的数据，工程师们发明了更高级的武器，比如操作变换，也就是OT以及无冲突复制数据类型，称简称CRDT。
[S01] 这里我们必须得把那个把单字ice变成nice,然后再加感叹号的例子给揉碎了讲一讲，因为它太巧妙了。
[S02] 这个例子很经典。
[S01] 听众朋友们，你可以想象一下，现在屏幕上有一个词ice，冰块的冰，你想把它变成nice美好，所以你在最前面，也就是索引位置零的地方插入了一个字母N。
[S02] 但这同时我在地球另一端想把它变成感叹语ice,所以我跑到最后面，也就是索引位置三的地方插入了一个感叹号。
[S01] 这时候冲突就来了。如果系统只是像刻板的机器一样记录索引位置，用户A在索引零插入N,用户B在索引三插入感叹号。
[S02] 当系统试图合并时，它先执行你的操作，变成了nice.这时候原来在索引三的那个空位，因为前面挤进来一个N,已经被字母E占有了。
[S01] 如果系统盲目地继续执行你的指令，在索引三插入感叹号，结果就会变成nice点一。
[S02] 完全乱套了，单词被生生劈开了。
[S01] 哇，所以这就是为什么同时编辑文档那么难，
[S01] 那OT是怎么解决这个问题呢？
[S02] OT的核心在于变换。当系统准备应用我的在索引三插入感叹号的操作时，它会敏锐地察觉到等等。在执行这个动作之前，
[S02] 另一个人已经在前面插入了一个字母。
[S01] 系统意识到了前面的位置变动。
[S02] 对，于是OT引擎会自动把我的指令进行变换，把插入位置从三悄悄向后顺延到了四，这样感叹号就完美的落在了nice的最后面。
[S01] 这是一种基于相对位置的动态计算，很聪明，但是这听起来计算量极其庞大啊，
[S01] 那CRDT呢？我听说这是一种完全不同的思路。
[S02] 是的，CRDT走的是一条更加颠覆的路线，它干脆放弃了索引这个概念。
[S02] 在CRDT的世界里，它给每一个字母都颁发了一个全宇宙唯一的身份ID,而且这个ID带有排序功能。
[S01] 给字母发身份证。
[S02] 对，比如I的ID是一A,C是二A,一是三A.
[S01] 啊，我明白了，所以当我想要在最前面插入N的时候，
[S01] 系统不是记录在位置零插入，而是记录在身份为一A的字符前面插入N.
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 而你要插入感叹号，
[S01] 系统记录的是在身份为三A的字符后面插入。这样一来，我问系统先处理谁的指令，
[S01] 网络怎么乱序，
[S01] 系统都能精准地把它们安插在正确的位置。
[S02] 完全不需要像OT那样费尽心思去计算位置偏移，这就是给数据赋予绝对坐标的魅力。但是不管是OT还是CRDT,都在说明一件事。
[S01] 什么事？
[S02] 让多个领导者互相协商处理冲突，是一件极其耗费心智和算力的事情。
[S01] 确实，既然协调多个领导者这么让人头疼，那干脆我们一不做二不休，
[S01] 连领导者都不要了。
[S02] 哈哈，
[S02] 直接掀桌子。
[S01] 对，彻底走向无政府状态会怎样？这就带领我们进入了今天最疯狂的第三个阵营，也就是无主复制，或者叫Dynamo风格架构。
[S02] 在无主架构里，人人平等，没有任何节点拥有特权，也不存在什么主厨和帮厨。
[S01] 那怎么写入数据？
[S02] 当你作为一个客端想要写入数据时，你不会去找什么领导，
[S02] 而是直接把你的数据像撒网一样，同时丢给系统里的所有节点。
[S01] 如果有的节点刚好断网了呢？
[S02] 无所谓，只要有足够多的节点接受到了数据，
[S02] 这次写入就算成功了。
[S01] 等等，如果没有任何领导者来拍板，什么是真相？那你怎么知道你读到的数据是不是最新的？如果我运气不好，刚好向那个错过了更新的节点查询数据怎么办？
[S02] 这就是无主架构的核心魔法所在了。
[S02] 系统通过一种叫做仲裁的机制，
[S02] quorum来保证你总能读到最新的真相。
[S01] 仲裁这个概念听起来有点抽象，呃，让我试试用一个日常的逻辑来拆解一下。
[S02] 你试试。
[S01] 假设系统里一共有三个节点，如果我每次写入数据都必须确保至少有两个节点成功记录了。
[S02] 嗯，这是写入的前提。
[S01] 然后我每次读取数据也必须同时向至少两个节点去询问，对吧？因为二加二等于四大于总数三，所以无论我怎么挑，我询问的那两个节点里，绝对必然包含了至少一个拥有最新数据的节点，这是基础的数学集合重叠原理。
[S02] 你完全抓住了本质，这就是分布式系统里著名的W加R大于N公式。只要写入和读取的节点集合有交集，那个交集里的节点就是掌握最新真相的证人。
[S01] 这太巧妙了，但那些宕机后重新上线的节点怎么办？他们手里的数据是旧的，难道就让他们一直戳下去吗？
[S02] 当然不会，无主系统有很强的自我愈合能力，
[S02] 最常见的一种叫独修复。
[S01] 怎么个修复法？
[S02] 比如你刚才同时向两个节点读取数据，节点A告诉你比分是一点零，节点B告诉你比分是零点零，
[S02] 客端对比时间戳发现A是最新的，于是他把一点零返回给你的同时，会顺手向B发送一个更新指令。
[S01] 嘿，你落后了，赶紧把比分改成一点零。
[S02] 对，这就叫独修复。大家在互相借阅笔记的过程中，顺手帮你纠错。
[S01] 这种互帮互复制设计真的很有机。但是在这种彻底无政府，大家同时接受数据的环境里，
[S01] 其实隐藏着一个终极的哲学危机。
[S02] 哲学危机。
[S01] 对啊，如果没有任何人排队，也没有领导者来盖绝对的时间戳。
[S01] 那到底什么叫同时发生？或者用专业名字说，什么叫并发？在我们的常识里，并发就是两件事在时钟上的同一秒钟发生。
[S02] 这恰恰是分布式系统里最烦直觉的一点。
[S02] 在分布式系统里，由于每台机器的时钟都可能有一点点误差，
[S02] 物理时间是极其不可靠的，所以判断并发根本不看绝对时间。
[S01] 那看什么？
[S02] 并发真正的定义是彼此不知道对方的存在。
[S01] 彼此不知道对方的存在。
[S02] 对，也就是没有因果上的前后继承关系。就算两件事在地球的物理时间上相隔了一整天，只要他们在修改数据时，
[S02] 都没有基于对方修改过后的状态进行，哪怕隔了二十四小时，在数据库眼里，他们就是并发的。
[S01] 这个概念，
[S01] 资料里的那个购物车因果依赖图展现得极其生动。
[S02] 我们可以还原一下那个场景。
[S01] 假设你想买早餐，客户一往购物车里加了一盒牛奶，
[S01] 系统记录下来，并给这个状态打了个唯一的版本号。接着客户二的网络有点问题，他在完全不知道购物车里已经有牛奶的情况下，往里面加了鸡蛋。
[S02] 这个时候数据库拿到这两条指令就懵了。
[S01] 对，他发现鸡蛋并不是在牛奶的基础上添加的，这两个动作互相不知道对方，所以数据库绝对不会擅作主张，用鸡蛋去覆盖牛奶。
[S02] 没错，数据库会把牛奶和鸡蛋作为两个平行的兄弟版本同时保留下来。
[S02] 系统会使用一种叫做版本向量的技术来追踪这种复杂的血缘关系。
[S01] 就像是数据的一张精密的族谱。
[S02] 对，一张族谱。
[S01] 那这族谱到底怎么用呢？假设客户一随后又想加面粉，他在提交面粉的时候，必须带上之前的版本号，告诉系统，嘿，我是基于已经有牛奶的那个版本往里加面粉的。
[S02] 系统一听懂了，面粉是牛奶的合法后代，所以系统可以安全地用牛奶加面粉覆盖掉原来的牛奶。
[S01] 但是，
[S01] 系统依然会保留那颗孤立的鸡蛋。
[S02] 因为鸡蛋是另一条世界线上的产物，直到最后当你要结账的时候，
[S02] 系统会把这两个兄弟版本一起丢给你的手机，让客端在本地把它们核定成牛奶、面粉、鸡蛋。
[S01] 呵呵，最后一次性写回数据库。
[S02] 非常精彩的推演。
[S02] 版本向量确保了系统永远不会弄丢任何一次没有因果关系的写入。
[S01] 那么把我们今天聊的这一切拼凑起来，到底意味着什么？
[S01] 我们今天穿越了数据复制的三大阵营，
[S01] 单主复制用独裁换来了秩序，但代价是无聊的瓶颈和各种时空错乱的幻觉。
[S01] 呵呵。
[S02] 多主复制让全球异地协作成为可能，却让我们陷入了冲突合并的无尽泥潭。
[S01] 而无主复制干脆放弃了领导者，用仲裁公式和版本向量在混乱中寻找交集。这不仅是技术的演进，更像是在这三个极端之间寻找平衡点。
[S02] 确实在这个世界里，
[S02] 永远没有完美的标准答案，只有可用性、延迟和一致性之间永恒的权衡。
[S01] 这是个艰难的三角恋。
[S02] 哈，是的。如果你仔细想象，今天我们讨论的所有这些复杂的架构、协议和算法，其实都在试图解决同一个问题，反抗物理学的基本限制。
[S01] 物理限制。
[S02] 对，
[S02] 系统判定并发不依赖于绝对时间，这其实跟物理学中的狭义相对论不谋而合。信息传播的速度不可能超过光速，只要信息还没有传到你这里，哪怕它在宇宙的另一端已经发生了一万年。
[S01] 对你来说，它也是未知的并发的。
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 这给我们的探索留下了一个巨大且迷人的悬念。
[S01] 我们人类目前在地球上的网络延迟，大概也就是几十到几百毫秒。现代的这些数据库用尽了各种奇技淫巧，勉强还能应付得过来。
[S02] 算是勉强及格。但想象一下，几十年后，如果我们在火星建立了殖民地，地球与火星之间的通信，哪怕是以光速传播，单程也需要几分钟到几十分钟。
[S01] 呃，在那种延迟尺度下，同时这个词彻底失去了意义。
[S02] 绝对的。当你和你在火星上的朋友试图在同一个云文档里编辑同一行文字时，基于我们今天聊的这些复制法则，它还能奏效吗？恐怕不行了。Lww会导致大规模的数据被无情抹除，而CRDT可能会因为积累了海量的兄弟版本，让内存彻底崩溃。
[S01] 如果光速这道物理墙是不可逾越的，
[S01] 那未来的新技术数据库该如何运作？
[S01] 我们是否需要一种全新的数据物理学？
[S02] 这是一个留给未来的超级难题。
[S01] 这儿的问题就留给正在收听的你。
[S01] 在下一次你的APP卡顿了半秒钟的瞬间去独自咀嚼吧，感谢你的陪伴，
[S01] 我们下次再见。